bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce jeudi 15 juillet au kosovo le
retour d'ibrahim rugova chef modéré
président élu provoque un enthousiasme
populaire mais l'on attend beaucoup de
la présence désormais effective de
bernard kouchner administrateurs pour
les nations unies au possible
la reprise des exportations de viande
bovine britannique autorisé à partir du
1er août suscite bien des interrogations
chez les éleveurs et les consommateurs
européens mise au point d'un traitement
simple et peu cher pouvant éviter la
transmission d'une mère à son enfant du
virus du sida
l'adjudant chef de gendarmerie eric
boullier qui participent à l'opération
dite de la paillote donne sa version des
faits et met en cause la préfecture
corse sport cyclisme 11e étape
insolite avec la victoire du champion
belge dirk scène ce qu'il devance le
peloton de plus de 22 minutes
ce jeudi 15 juillet après stinat la
capitale du kosovo l'arrivée de deux
hommes provoqué espoir et enthousiasme
espoir de reconstruction
d'administration et de justice eulex
bernard kouchner administrateurs pour
les nations unies de cette province où
déjà six cent mille réfugiés sont de
retour soudain confronté à une
cohabitation difficile avec les
habitants serbes enthousiasme manifeste
pour ibrahim rugova ce chef modéré
pacifiste président élu mais partenaire
encombrant pour l'ofce cas séparatiste
officiellement pourtant nous checa s'est
réjouit de son retour à pristina
reportage de notre envoyé spécial agnès
vahramian et nathalie gallet
c'est le président que les albanais
c'est plus choisis
donc lors d'élections clandestine mais
toléré par les autorités c'est les
albanais attendaient son retour depuis
un mois et demi
charismatique ibrahim morin avait en
effet pour beaucoup failli on annonçait
zola - de milosevic avait il devra
prendre la guerre on le disait politique
moment le voilà à clame cet homme
explique que ronald certes mais qu'il
vaut mieux tard que jamais qu'il ne lui
en cette jeune fille gobain unissent les
albanais et qu'il s'entende avec les
chick le kosovo liban avait salué par
hugo va mais pendant son absence son
grand rival
hashim thaçi porte-parole de l'ofce cas
a déjà constitué un gouvernement non élu
mais au travail
c'est avec thaçi l'homme fort ergo va le
légitime que bernard kouchner va devoir
négocier l'arrivée concomitante de
kouchner ergo va ne devait rien au
hasard aujourd'hui bernard kouchner a
besoin d'interlocuteurs rugova le non
violent et le plus fréquentable je ne
suis pas neutre
je suis impartiale comme l'ont été nos
amis ici et bien sûr monsieur rugova est
un des interlocuteurs dont je souhaite
car la démocratie exige que plusieurs
intellect peur soit en face de nous pour
construire petit à petit step by step
progressivement ce qui n'a jamais été le
cas ici
retour à l'autonomie démocratie ibrahim
rugova attend avec impatience les
élections que doit organiser l'onu c'est
d'après midi il a retrouvé sa maison de
pristina dans laquelle il était assigné
à résidence par les serbes
il a aussi enlevé son célèbre foulards
de soie il n'en a plus besoin dit il
c'était le symbole d'une voix étouffée
au kosovo pour celui que l'on appelle
toujours le docteur bernard kouchner la
reconstruction du pays passe aussi par
le règlement des besoins sanitaires
urgents à l'hôpital de mitrovic situé
dans l'enclavé serbe de cette ville une
administratice viennent d'être nommés
par la cellule des nations unies elle
doit faire travailler ensemble médecins
serbes et albanais dans un établissement
évidemment très démunis
ce système mis en place à l'hôpital de
mitrovica pourrait servir d'exemple pour
tous le kosovo reportage valérie
fournier et frédéric basket
ils sont médecins infirmiers ou simple
cuisinier et chaque jour c'est sous
escorte qu'ils rejoignent leur lieu de
travail
une petite victoire pour ses 168
albanais qui ont réussi à retrouver leur
emploi à l'hôpital de mitrovica en zone
serbe et l'épreuve de force et
quotidiennes entre le personnel
hospitalier des deux communautés
outre et ce médecin de l'année a tenu ce
matin à nous emmener dans son service de
gynécologie l'infirmière serbe de
permanence a laissé ses femme albanaise
qui ont accouché et subi une césarienne
dans leur sens aucune d'elles n'a reçu
de soins sauf cette femme serbe
l'infirmière serbe ne m'a rien donné
même pas de serviettes hygiéniques
je n'ai eu unis pansements ni
médicaments et les médecins albanais
n'ont rien pu nous donner car il n'y
avait pas accès
calme et la peur et la haine dans cet
hôpital c'est la mission de muriel
arrondo un administrateur civil qui doit
faire coexister les deux communautés une
mission mais les deux diplomaties et de
fermeté
récit du matériel nécessaire de dire que
les autres n'ont pas car ni face à face
sont en constante remise saint albanais
et serbes et l'administrateur doit être
aussi un médiateur maintenant s'ils
s'avèrent exacts de cette infirmière à
n'est pas prodigué des soins de ce qui
est nécessaire
sonnant s'est impatienté albanaise et
bien je la bombe au crest et je prends
le jeudi saint paul ouais on va y
arriver on va y arriver
c'est une question de temps et d'être
fait qu'une question de temps et de
travail de patience surtout d'autant
plus qu'une fois les tensions oublier
ces deux médecins albanais et serbes ont
poursuivi leur travail en commun et
qu'une entente be possible quand les
médecins albanais sont revenus ils ont
refusé de reconnaître notre autorité
comme nous la leur il ne peut pas y
avoir de chef il ne peut y en avoir
qu'un mais le pari n'est pas gagné pour
l'administrateur civil car ce service de
gynécologie et le sol de l'hôpital ou
serbes et albanais comme unique et
oeuvre malgré tout côte à côte pour le
bien des malades à compter du 1er août
prochain la grande bretagne pourra
reprendre ses exportations de viande
bovine
la commission européenne a écouté tous
les avis des comités scientifiques
compétents et mis ainsi fin à un embargo
décidé le 27 mars 96 en raison de
l'épidémie de d'encéphalite spongiforme
bovine esb dite maladie de la vache
folle mais la reprise des exportations
se fera sous contrôle le royaume-uni
détenait la quasi totalité des cas
recensés en europe c'est à dire un peu
plus de cent soixante seize mille pour
france 2 jean bernard schmidt et steve
rosenblum se sont rendus chez un éleveur
britannique victime des conséquences de
cet embargo
celui ci en trois ans aura coûté 2
milliards 300 millions de francs de
pertes à l'agriculture de grande
bretagne
george atkinson a toujours nourri ces
bêtes de la même manière
du blé mélangés à des protéines jamais
il n'a utilisé de farines animales
aujourd'hui interdite même avant la
crise c'était pour lui un gage de
qualité grâce à cette précaution aucune
de ces 200 bêtes n'a dû être abattus par
les services vétérinaires et pourtant
ces trois années d'embargo sur le boeuf
sont les plus difficiles qu'ait jamais
connu son exploitation et me pèse de
saison il va la même valeur qui avant la
crise ça a été très difficile
nous ne pouvions faire aucun projet
d'avenir parce que nous ne savions pas
ce qui allait se passer
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois
depuis longtemps qu'il faut faire des
projets bruxelles a décidé de lever
l'embargo sur le buzz britanniques en
partie à cause de cette étiquette
comporte désormais chaque animal
grâce à elle les services vétérinaires
entendent faire la preuve de leur
efficacité
autrefois contestées ils savent
parfaitement quand l'animal est né où il
est allé et enfin où il a été abattu
soulagement également ce matin sur le
grand marché londonien de la viande
et pourtant les professionnels savent
qu'ils auront bien des obstacles à
franchir
l'embargo n'est qu'en partie levé aucune
bête vivante ne pourra être exportée
uniquement de la viande désossée
d'animaux âgés de six à trente mois avec
toutes les garanties sur la mer et puis
il faudra regagner tous les marchés
perdus à retrouver la confiance des
consommateurs il faut leur faire acheter
notre boeuf pour qu'il réalise qu'il est
bon cela veut dire qu'il faut le vendre
à un prix compétitif
or aujourd'hui il coûte plus cher que
les autres a produit pour les
professionnels ce sera donc un processus
très long les plus optimistes espèrent
exporter cette année 5000 tonnes de
viande bovine il en vendait à l'étranger
250 mille tonnes par an avant la crise
alors même sous condition l'exportation
de viande de boeuf britannique ne
rassure pas totalement consommateurs
éleveurs et emilio gutierrez vétérinaire
en europe
il s'est même trouvé un ministre
allemand du land de rhénanie pour
estimer que la politique de l'union
européenne prend les gens pour des
nigauds en france des unions de
consommateurs craignent qu'une levée de
l'embargo prématuré enquête cyrille
devaud
dans ce supermarché de normandie le
consommateur y regardent à deux fois
avant d'acheter son bifteck la crise de
la vache folle l'a rendu vigilant mais
le retour du boeuf anglais dans les
rayons ne semble pas l'inquiéter
je pense quand même que maintenant ils
censés y est nécessaire pour que l'on
n'ait pas de problèmes
tu peux presque sait rien il ya eu la
maladie chez eux qu'ils faut
spécialement les courbes d'un mur c'est
vraiment les prix sont intéressants et
tout ça j'achèterai du moment que c'est
un vente
ça doit être bon pour la viande
française pas de problème d'information
l'étiquetage est réglementé depuis
février 97 en un coup d'oeil on peut
tout connaître de sa pièce de boeuf son
origine en l'occurrence france sa
catégorie bof sa race laitière sa date
d'emballage sa date de limite de
consommation
mais ce luxe de détails n'est pas
obligatoire pour les viandes d'origine
étrangère si rien n'est mentionné le
boeuf peut venir d'espagne de pologne ou
à partir du 1er août d'angleterre autre
sujet d'inquiétude le boeuf utilisé par
la restauration collective
ce soit cantine ou restaurants nous
avons la crainte que les anglais aient
fait de revendre leur viande via ce
biais où l'on fait très très bien que le
consommateur n'est pas du tout informés
sur l'origine des produits qu'ils
avalent dans ce genre de lieu pour le
boeuf français la traçabilité est en
principe infaillible depuis deux ans les
contrôles ont été renforcés les
charolais de louge haillan éleveurs dans
l'aube sont sous haute surveillance
ici pas de farines animales à l'oreille
de chaque bête un numéro
d'identification
cette attestation sanitaire certifie que
l'animal est en parfaite santé des
animaux en revue les éleveurs français
croient aimerait que les troupes
britanniques et une traçabilité aussi
conséquente que celle qui en france
qu'on puisse y vivre une vache de sa
naissance jusqu'à sa mort et la
profession agricole française s'est
imposée des contraintes
nous aimerions que celles qui sont
imposés en angleterre soit si stricte
depuis le début de l'année le nombre de
cas de vache folle a diminué en france
mais pas en angleterre
sur les cinq premiers mois de 1999
il ya eu près de 80 hors ça fait quand
même beaucoup pour deux fois moins de
bovins qu'en france où il n'y a eu que
douze cas rappelons le pour 1999 le
gouvernement français rappelle donc que
le principe de précaution restent
prioritaires ce malgré la levée de
l'embargo par bruxelles à l'origine des
mesures de précaution prises contre
cette maladie dite de la vache folle il
y a les démonstrations scientifiques que
cette maladie puisse se transmettre à
l'homme donnant ainsi une variante
mortelle de la maladie de creutzfeldt
jakob
l'explication benoît thevenet lorsque
les britanniques découvrir à la
télévision ces images souvenirs d'une
jeune fille alors bien portante claire
tomkins atteinte de la maladie de
creutzfeldt jacob était déjà morte
son cas est celui de 40 autres personnes
ont brutalement révéla l'angleterre
l'ampleur de l'épidémie en 97 soit plus
de dix ans après l'apparition des
premiers cas de vache folle en grande
bretagne une équipe de scientifiques
britanniques établi de façon formelle un
lien entre l'encéphalopathie spongiforme
c'est à dire la maladie de la vache
folle et la nouvelle forme de la maladie
de creutzfeldt jakob
au fil des expériences sur les souris et
les singes les chercheurs ont obtenu
l'assurance que le même prix y ont été à
l'origine de la maladie chez l'animal et
chez l'homme qu'elle introduit on peut
pas faire des expérimentations humaines
vous avez raison mais ce que
on a montré c'est que la souche de prion
en cause et est la même chez la vache
celle ci est un argument majeur pour
penser que c'est la maladie si on peut
estimer que la maladie de la vache folle
sera éradiquée d'ici quelques années on
ne sait en revanche rien de ce que sera
l'évolution de la maladie humaine
les chercheurs estiment que l'incubation
peut durer jusqu'à 30 ans depuis le
début de l'épidémie un seul cas de
nouveaux variants de creutzfeldt jacob a
été répertoriés en france un autre en
irlande mais 40 cas comme celui de
maurice qu'à la reine ont été recensés
en grande bretagne dont dix au cours du
dernier trimestre 98 au lieu de 2 à 5
habituellement c'est une donnée
inquiétante
nous attendons impatiemment c'est le cas
de le dire
les quelques six mois ou l'année qui
vient pour savoir si cette tendance se
confirme
ou bien si c'était juste un artefact
c'est à dire si c'était juste un petit
accident de relever de données
épidémiologiques
impossible donc de prévoir quoi que ce
soit suivant les chercheurs les
estimations du nombre de malades à venir
aussi entre 800 personnes et 180 me un
test pour découvrir la présence de la
maladie chez l'homme est bien en cours
d'élaboration outre-manche mais on ne
dispose toujours d'aucune piste pour
venir à bout de la maladie pour éviter
la transmission du sida de la mère à
l'enfant un traitement vient d'être
découvert quand on sait que chaque jour
dans le monde 1600 enfants chaque jour
sont infectées par le sida et que la
quasi totalité d'entre eux naissent dans
les pays du sud les plus pauvres on
mesure l'importance de cette découverte
il y aurait actuellement 830 mille
enfants contaminés dans le monde
le traitement mis au point après les
tests réalisés notamment en ouganda
serait certes long mais peu onéreux ce
qui est essentiel pour les enfants des
pays en état de sous développement
commentaire j de mariner dans certaines
régions de l'ouganda une femme enceinte
sur trois est séropositive un bébé sur
deux risque d'être contaminé les
traitements existants sont dures à
supporter il entraîne des effets
secondaires et surtout leurs coûts les
rangs inabordable ce médicament la
névirapine pourrait tout changer une
seule prise pour la mère au moment de
l'accouchement
trois jours de traitement pour l'enfant
les chercheurs américains le test avec
succès depuis trois mois
étude avait pour but de découvrir le
traitement le plus court et le mieux
adapté à une femme enceinte contaminé un
traitement administré à la fin de la
grossesse ans durant l'accouchement
ainsi qu'aux nouveaux nés l'objectif
étant d'empêcher la transmission du sida
de la mère à l'enfant mais par des
moyens adaptés et financièrement
abordable pour les patients qui vivent
dans des pays en développement 4 dollars
c'est le coût de la prise en ministre et
à la mère et l'enfant il en faut
actuellement plusieurs centaines pour un
moindre résultat
car la névirapine a fait tomber le taux
de contamination à 13% et le traitement
combiné un autre médicament pourrait
s'améliorer
une équipe française y travaillent nous
cherchons à savoir si données de la
névirapine en plus d'un traitement par
laser t augmente l'efficacité de la z t
à prévenir la transmission du virus de
la mère à l'enfant et un essai de ce
type sous l'égide de l'agencé céréales
de recherche au sida française devrait
débuter en afrique dans les prochains
mois actuellement dans le monde millions
d'enfants sont séropositifs contaminée
dès leur naissance
et puis en cette période de vacances en
france je veux attirer votre attention
sur un appel lancé par les services de
l'hôpital trousseau à paris
les dons de sang et de plaquettes font
gravement défaut les enfants atteints de
leucémie ont besoin de vos dons alors
aussi les deux numéros de téléphone que
vous pouvez faire entre 9 heures et 17
heures chaque jour pour aider ses jeunes
patients de l'hôpital trousseau voici
numérotée fun donc
01 44 73 66 23 44 73 67 88 entre 9
heures et 17 des retombées tragique pour
les fêtes du 14 juillet hier soir outre
des incidents à paris en haute savoie 12
personnes ont été blessées par deux
fusées tirées lors du feu d'artifice à
arbois dans le jura tandis qu'à
saint-etienne une femme est décédée des
suites de blessures causées par une
fusée tirée à saint-just-saint-rambert
dans la loire et sept autres personnes
ont été blessées lors de ce même
accident
reportage virginie fichet et gilles
perret
au bord du fleuve la foule a cédé la
place aux uniformes dans la population
le traumatisme est profond
les spectateurs de la nu sur vire cet
instant où cinq fusées ont dévié de leur
trajectoire
l'une d'elles s'écrasant sur le public
au fur et à mesure où des tirs continué
à s'approcher de plus en plus vers les
ports et les gens en traitant été
brûlées parce que en explosant les
morceaux de feux d'artifice sont venus
aspergé la foule en fête hier soir vers
23 heures ils étaient plusieurs milliers
sur la rive droite de la loire le feu
d'artifice étaient tirés depuis la rive
opposée entre les deux points plus de
200 mètres de distance
selon les premières constatations
l'affaissement d'une rampe de lancement
serait en partie à l'origine de
l'accident il très tôt n'était peut-être
pas fixé de la manière dont ils auraient
dû l'être puisque ce genre de tréteaux
sont là pour régler la hauteur du tir la
trajectoire est donc évidemment c'est
primordial quand on tire à feu
d'artifice que de s'assurer de la
solidité de ses tréteaux la gendarmerie
a également établi que le type de fusil
utilisé et l'angle de tir choisi n'était
pas adapté trop puissante
la charge aurait déstabilisé les
tréteaux une erreur de manipulation que
la commune ne comprend pas on a fait
tirer ce feu d'artifice par la même
société et celle qui nous le tir depuis
des années c'est une cité le
professionnel des gens qui ont les
habilitations pour le faire les feux
sont de plus en plus technique on n'est
plus à l'époque où un show étiez par les
pompiers du village
ce soir le directeur de la société est
l'un des cinq artificiers sont toujours
en garde à vue avant le feu d'artifice
d'hier malgré leur expérience ces
professionnels n'avait déposé aucune
déclaration préalable auprès de la
préfecture
selon le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur jean pierre chevènement toutes
les conditions sont maintenant réunies
pour un retour à la normale en corse
en attendant l'adjudant chef eric
boullier l'un des créateurs du groupe de
pelotons de sécurité de la préfecture
d'ajaccio
l'un des gendarmes mis en examen pour sa
participation d'un incendie de la
paillote chez francis raconte les
conditions de cette action eric boullier
dont le père fut l'un des gendarmes tués
à hoover nouvelle calédonie met en cause
la préfecture mais ne nomme pas le
préfet bernard bonne
c'est sa version de ce qui s'est passé
dans la nuit du 19 au 20 avril dernier
sur la plage de cala d'oro
entretien réalisé par michèle fines avec
jean piat pasteur pour l'adjudant chef
eric boullier la sphère des paillotes
commence début mars lorsque le chef du
gps le capitaine norbert ambrosse réunit
tous ces officiers
le capitaine en brosse nous a réuni un
matin les trois lieutenants et moi même
et donc nous disant vous savez ce qui
s'est passé cette nuit je deviendrai
jamais alors effectivement dit ben voilà
le colonel mazères et directeur de
cabinet monsieur pardini donc on est
maîtres le feu une paillote surtout
qu'on avait jamais parlé des paillotes
donc 10 rebonds et diot
donc on n'y croyait pas c'est pas
possible selon eric boullier
l'aria marina devait être la première
paillote incendiés le plan a échoué
alors le colonel mazères demande au gps
de continuer mission incendié cinq
paillote les gendarmes refusent trop
dangereux le colonel insiste le
capitaine doit transmettre à les hauts
revenus les revenus nous voir peut-être
trois jours après réunion il a dit ok
pas cinq périodes mais trois alors bons
rails a dit non c'est pas possible c'est
on va retrouver le même problème
5 3 10 15 annoncée on peut pas il est
reparti et puis il est revenu puis a dit
bon d'accord le connaître mais une le
préfet veut absolument qu'on fasse celle
de monsieur de chez francis et régulier
ce qu'on tentera d'emmener le commando
sur la plage avant de le récupérer mais
le lendemain en regardant la télévision
surprise et j'ai vu monsieur ferro avec
des tracts à la main devrait faire trois
régions corse le soir puisque c'est elle
qui c'est qu'a posé ça quand j'ai appelé
le lieutenant tavernier il me dit c'est
le capitaine qui a sorti de sa poche et
quand sur la plage moi-même qui n'était
pas au courant je lui ai demandé d'où ça
venait il m'a dit que quand elle mazères
lui avait donné que c'est à la
préfecture qu'on lui avait donné ses
tracts à déposer sur sur la plage et je
pense que ça a été caché plus ou moins
volontairement le côté des tracts parce
que moi les tracts ferro balance des
flics je savais pertinemment ce que ça
engendre et je suis militaire j'oublie
aux orres mais là c'est comme si je
mettais une croix dans le dos de
monsieur 013 de fusil
la sphère des paillotes a entraîné la
dissolution du gps à l'origine pourtant
le groupe avait d'autres missions
pendant des mois sont peu le temps
d'observation le pro à surveiller les
assassin présumé du préfet erignac
jusqu'au jour où la gendarmerie a été
dessaisi de l'enquêté pour savoir quand
même que la gendarmerie à ce moment là
et ça personne ne l'a dit avec 70% voire
80% du dossier du commando erignac
la gendarmerie a continué à travailler
sur les objectifs la gendarmerie non
leproux oui puisque l'agent leur temps
d'observation voilà bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr mais ça
les hommes ne venait pas de la dg il
venait de la préfecture eric boullier a
fait 40 jours de prison
comme tous les autres gendarmes du gps
il vient de retrouver une nouvelle
affectation
malgré tout il a décidé de quitter la
gendarmerie et de partir à la retraite
sur décision de la cour de cassation la
compagnie british airways est
définitivement condamné à indemniser les
passagers français de l'avion de cette
compagnie avion qui s'était posé au
lendemain de l'invasion du koweït en
août 98 peur l'irak sur l'aéroport de la
capitale koweïtienne avait été pris en
otage utilisés comme boucliers humains
la compagnie aérienne british airways
n'aurait pas dû poser son appareil
en outre 90 en france ces dernières 24
heures 39 départs de feux ont été
recensés dans les bouges rôle les
incendies ont été maîtrisés comme l'a
été celui du maquis de haute corse près
de saint florent pour prévenir la
détecter tout départ de feu les
départements le département du var
dispose d'une flotte de cinq
hélicoptères bombardiers d'eau équipés
d'un système de vidéo permettant une
surveillance permanente des massifs
menacée reportage de joël bruandet et
yann one ils sont peut-être moins
célèbre que les canadairs pourtant dans
le var les hélicoptères bombardiers
d'eau font partie du paysage depuis 12
ans mais désormais leur mission ne
s'arrête pas aux simples largage depuis
peu ces appareils sont en effet équipés
d'une sorte de vidéosurveillance
embarquée entre les mains de cet
officier des sapeurs-pompiers une caméra
numérique qui envoie grâce aux
satellites des photos des éventuels
incendie l'hélicoptère quant à lui est
localisable à tout instant grâce à une
balise gps
cette petite tache bleue au centre de
l'écran c'est notre hélicoptère moment
les suit on les perd pas de vue nous
sommes au centre de commandement des
sapeurs pompiers du var ici c'est le
règne de la radio m'a dit t'es quoi dit
ça
aujourd'hui le recours à des images
comme celles ci est de plus en plus
fréquents ici nous avons beaucoup de
radios beaucoup de téléphones on a de
grandes oreilles mais on est aveugle et
pour sortir de notre cécité et nous faut
des moyens
où on reçoit des images soient des
images indirecte par le positionnement
des immigrés faire soit des images
directes par une prise de vue caméra qui
va nous donner ici une petite vision du
terrain pourtant en termes de prévention
des feux de forêt rien ne remplace
l'oeil humain celui là du haut de cette
tour qui culmine à 800 mètres d'altitude
odette et son mari jean paul domine une
bonne partie du massif des maures à la
jumelle ou simplement à l'oeil nu
il passe les trois mois d'été à scruter
leur océans a eu cette forêt qu'ils
connaissent désormais par coeur l'état
de sécheresse
on doit être vigilant à peu près toute
heure là d'origine ou de la journée dont
on n'a pas le temps de s'ennuyer
et cet été comme chaque année guetteurs
pilote ou sapeurs pompiers au sol font
partie d'un dispositif impressionnant au
total dans le var près de 40 millions de
francs sont investis pour préserver le
deuxième département le plus boisé de
france dans des proportions et
évidemment incomparables il y
actuellement des milliers d'hectares en
feu en alaska et des dizaines de
milliers d'hectares ravagés par des
incendies en russie
au point que le président russe boris
eltsine a dû quitter sa résidence située
à une centaine de kilomètres de moscou
on signale également des dizaines de
milliers d'hectares en feu dans le sud
de la sibérie la chine annonce qu'elle
possède la maîtrise de la technologie de
la bombe à neutrons plusieurs rapports
américains laissé planer le doute
mais la chine a fait cette annonce
publique pour bien montrer sa
détermination alors que la tension avec
les dirigeants de taiwan augmente
sérieusement comme un terreau jérôme ni
il ya longtemps déjà que la chine
populaire est fière d'être une puissance
nucléaire
depuis 1964 date de l'explosion dans le
désert du loch nord de la première bombe
un don le champignon soulevé
d'enthousiasmé les petits soldats de mao
45 essais en tout jusqu'à 1996 année où
la chine signent le traité international
sur l'interdiction des essais nucléaires
on se doutait que l' empire du milieu
maîtriser la bombe à neutrons
extrêmement irradiante avec la
particularité de tuer les hommes en
laissant le matériel pratiquement intact
mais aujourd'hui c'est enfin officiel ce
porte-parole vient de l'annoncer le
gouvernement chinois détient la bombe à
neutrons
c'est une réponse aux accusations
d'espionnage nucléaire d'une commission
parlementaire américaine sous entendu
nous n'avons pas besoin de votre
technologie
il ne mâche pas ses mots le représentant
de cette chine qui prétend être le
dernier pays du monde à savoir encore
dire non aux états unis et avec des
arguments de choc
la pollution de l'eau dans le
département du pas de calais et à liévin
précisément prive d'eau potable depuis
une semaine plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes c'est la pollution
d'une nappe souterraine par des produits
dérivés de l'éther qui est à l'origine
de cette situation du coup les ventes
d'eaux minérales ont cadré plaît à
liévin un projet de loi est actuellement
à l'étude pour rendre obligatoire la
protection des piscines privées il faut
savoir que 40 enfants décèdent chaque
année en se noyant dans les piscines
privées et le plus souvent en raison de
l'inattention des adultes il existe
plusieurs systèmes de sécurité l'un de
ces systèmes étaient mis au point par le
père d'un enfant décédé
explications avec l'anc est d'olivier
theron et didier boom c'est la deuxième
cause de mortalité chez les moins de 4
ans l'histoire tragique se répète tous
les ans quelques minutes d'inattention
des parents un faux mouvement et c'est
la noyade
dominique a perdu son fils comme ça dany
avait 4 ans en été dans le salon et il
jouait dans le terrain derrière et
en quelques secondes on est venu là dans
la piscine ont alors qu'il n'y avait
jamais on puisse jamais sans ses
brassards et ce jour-là bon l'été à la
piscine et il est descendu les escaliers
voilà ça se passe en quelques secondes
tout le monde était là même sa soeur qui
a 13 ans qui sait très bien nager qui
est à côté de la piscine qui a pas vu
dominique pour que ça n'arrive plus à
mise au point un système d' alerte une
sorte de barrière infrarouge qui entoure
la piscine avec des capteurs et qui
déclenche une sirène quand l'enfant
s'approche trop près de l'eau il a
développé l'idée avec un ami industriels
et fait breveter le système c'est
toujours lors de quelques minutes
d'absence ou un coup de fil ou quelque
chose ou ou même dans le cas d'une
barrière le portail qui restent ouverts
où l'enfant qu'ils escaladent que
l'accident arrive
le problème c'est qu'il faut que les
parents soient avertis
d'autres systèmes existent aussi comme
les barrières qui entourent les piscines
et un projet de loi est à l'étude pour
rendre obligatoire ces protections en
cas d'accident il est nécessaire de
prévenir les secours
et tout de suite de prodiguer des
premiers gestes il faut commencer à
faire ce qu'on appelle le bouche à
bouche le massage cardiaque
la réanimation initial bien peu de
parents savent la faire cette
réanimation il faut il faut essayer de
faire quelques je pense que c'est le
bouche à bouche improvisé un
bouche-à-bouche improvisé un massage
cardiaque chaque année il y environ 300
noyade qui occasionne 40 décès alors
pour que l'été ne se transforme pas en
cauchemar
il vaut mieux rendre les enfants
insubmersible du sport du cyclisme le
tour de france avec une 11e étape où le
gros du peloton a semblé s'endormir fort
peu inquiet d'une échappée de coureurs
mal classés coureurs qui ont quand même
réussi à franchir la ligne d'arrivée à
saint-etienne avec quelques 22 minutes
d'avancé le champion de belgique loudot
dirksen ce qu'il l'a emporté
commentaires florent gautreau yul
brynner ne faisait pas de vélo marco
pantani ne fait pas le tour pas d'erreur
ce divin chauve qui lève les bras n'est
autre que ludo dierckxsens le champion
de belgique a réussi là où tous les
autres avait échoué depuis le début du
tour
une réussite qu'il doit d'abord à une
échappée précoce en compagnie de six
autres coureurs qui vont compter jusqu'à
16 minutes d'avancé sur un peloton
serein qui laissent faire
dans le groupe des sept un seul français
laurent lefèvre il court le tour pour la
première fois et il rêvait d'une
victoire à saint-etienne les devants et
quelques minutes dans le dernier col
lefebvre ne résiste pas à la tacc de
dirk sense et tout le groupe explose
personne ne reverra le champion belge
qui assure sa victoire dans la longue
descente vers saint-etienne une étape
qui ne change rien puisque armstrong est
toujours en tête mais une étape qui fait
du bien à ceux qui croient aux vertus de
l'effort solitaire
du tennis demain à pop début des quarts
de finale de la coupe davis opposant la
france au brésil cotées françaises
cédric pioline et sébastien grosjean
joueront les parties en simple face à
furnes d'om-lille génie mais surtout à
gustavo kuerten présentation christelle
bertrand et maryse richer au tennis on
ne prend pas tous au pied de la lettre
mais aujourd'hui france brésil c'est une
référence les hommes de forget aussi
aimerait chanter et un et deux et trois
zéro
l'équipe de france est déjà dans le ton
en portant le maillot
sébastien grosjean a laissé le sien au
vestiaire pourtant c'est bien lui le
bleu de l'équipe
le marseillais est sélectionné pour la
première fois le maillot des
footballeurs c'est un cadeau clin d'oeil
cela lui plairait d'imiter les champions
du monde c'est à la seule baisse qui est
arrivé avec des maillots avec nos noms
et les numéros derrière donc je sens que
c'est vraiment très sympathique de sa
part ça rappelle l'excellent souvenir
en espérant aussi bien que l'équipe de
france de foot les brésiliens ne sont
pas du tout du même avis gustavo kuerten
le numéro un de l'équipe a comme qui
dirait une légère amnésie à propos de
l'événement j'oublie les choses très
facilement le sort a décidé de faire
d'abord jouer sébastien grosjean contre
gustavo kuerten ensuite pioline prendra
le relais contre melli génie pour ce
quart de finale les français sont
confiants ils ont tous choisi mais le
capitaine ne veut surtout pas se
considérer comme favori vous êtes venir
ici choisi la surface on a choisi les
balles on va pas commencer à parler ces
choses là puisque bon c'était c'était
vraiment un choix qui est délibéré
qui nous avantage à priori au pays du
basket les français s'accordent quelques
moments de détente
les joueurs se sont bien préparés pour
affronter le brésil en plus ils savent
capot on veut compter sur la chance de
la musique avec le chanteur compositeur
nigérian keziah jones qui publie un
troisième album
ce guitariste mettant en musique ses
impressions d'afrique marie-josée juin
jean-louis melun nous retrouver à
londres chez lui après avoir assisté au
spectacle qu'il a donné à la cigale à
paris son territoire de prédilection la
jungle urbaine
peut-être parce que le chanteur nigérian
a commencé à gratter sa guitare dans le
métro
g
on se souvient encore des wise a misé là
c'est que dans 92 un succès cela que
j'achète petit truc mon miel bon l'eclj
à hénin journaux aujourd'hui keziah
jones vie et créé à londres dans un
univers là basquiat peinture montage
superposition assemblage de mots et
d'objets une deuxième passion et
pourquoi pas une exposition ça ça
représente la tournée là c'est 99 est la
seul support du tour fils d'un grand
chef guerrier du nigeria keziah gare de
l'afrique au coeur mais pour moi la
tristesse et de circonstance parce que
je suis africain je dois vivre en europe
à l'avenir et aux artistes hervé est
chaque jour où des bus pour situer un
livret à dire quand vous êtes français
vous réveiller tous les jours en sachant
que vous êtes français mais moi je dois
me remettre en question tous les jours
ci en 95 son deuxième album n'avait pas
séduit ses fans
le troisième écrit au nigeria est un
florilège de sensations
peut-être est-ce dû à sa rencontre avec
fela kuti figure mythique de la musique
africaine
ma philosophie la vie a été influencé
par la sienne prêté le plus courageux et
le plus héroïque
quand vous êtes jeune rencontré un mec
comme ça et on vous dit c'est comme ça
que je veux être prudent parce que c'est
un vrai
hier son nouveau tube sera-t-il de la
même veine que the reasons l'homme
toujours est il que la gestuelle féline
de keziah jones fascine le public autant
que sa musique sensuelle comme le
personnage
keziah jones est en tournée en france
actuellement et on le retrouvera à
l'olympia à la rentrée dans le kiosque
de la presse magazine deux nouveautés
tout d'abord tribeca 7 à news magazine
be made by trimestriel pour la
génération des 18 30 ans et puis la
sortie du magazine croisière c'est le
premier du genre consacrée à ce loisir
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de ce
journal je vous rappelle le principal
titre de la critique nous avons
développé l'arrivée au kosovo à pristina
du président élu monsieur ibrahim rugova
chef modérée des albanais arrivée dans
l' enthousiasme populaire monsieur
gouvart n'a fait qu'un aller retour il
reviendra au kosovo la semaine prochaine
et puis arrive également impressionné
aujourd'hui de l'administrateur des
nations unies monsieur bernard kouchner
il y as tout affairé à refaire et vite
et il faudra y mettre le prix avait-il
dit la météo dans quelques secondes sous
vous sera présentée par isabelle
martinet suivi point route de valérie
maurice suivi des nouveaux mondes au
népal avec antoine de maximy à 0 heures
50 le dernier journal de la rédaction
avec laurence ostolaza demain 7h 50 dans
les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevra monsieur
bani sadr l'ancien président iranien à
13h vous trouverez carole gaessler et
rachid arhab et à 20h béatrice schönberg
bonnes vacances à bientôt bonsoir merci
m